hey man it's me kevin smith welcome to
another scene study
this time of mall rats uh today we're
going to be looking specifically
at uh the thing that will follow me to
the grave
uh the thing that i'll probably be
remembered best for after i leave this
uh
most wonderful world the stink palm
scene
um i don't know where this came from
kids because i
i never did this in life and it wasn't a
thing i heard about you know where it
came from
the snowball scene in clerks that i
heard from somebody else i was like
that's [ __ ] cool
so as i'm writing mall rats i'm trying
to come up with a snowball equivalent
and i come up with the stink bomb
instead
so um it's you know the sad desperate
effort of a 24 25 year old kev smith
um to be raunchy but uh i've never
it's got no basis in life it's just
something i always thought
like man i hope people wash their hands
before they shake hands what if they
just have their hand on their pants
now in the age of kovid this is a horror
scene
this is a study in [ __ ] true terror
man the amount of
germs that are passed in this [ __ ]
sequence and stuff
oh it's horrible so enjoy
the stink bomb scenes you're gonna see
uh jason lee as the great brody bruce
jeremy london as t.s scott mosher gonna
pop in
as uh roddy mr svenning's assistant
and uh you might even see mr svening
himself
later on eating them [ __ ] uh
chocolate covered pretzels
the great michael rooker rooker you know
goes to comic cons all the time and
and says that still to this day there's
a percentage of people that come up for
pictures or
autographs that bring him a bag of
chocolate covered pretzels
um if you look at rooker in this scene
or in any of the entire movie
bald that's our lex luthor when i wrote
my superman script that's who i saw as
lex luthor was michael rooker he would
have been amazing
um so here it is ladies and gentlemen
from mall rats the stink palms
what do you think i don't trust it no
maybe he's calmed down a little bit you
know let's talk about it reasonably
reasonably schmeasonably you should go
over there and give him [ __ ]
kidding i'm trying to marry his daughter
all right so you can't scream at him but
after all he's done to you you should
still kind of stick it to him
how do you propose i do that you stink
pump it's a stink pong
you take your hand you stick it in your
ass like this you've been walking all
day and you're all so nervous so no
doubt you'll be sweaty as hell you
should see yourself right now grown man
with his hand down his pain
yeah i probably look like my old man ah
there now you shake hands with the guy
hey mrs vinnie how have you been
what's the point you know how long it
takes for that smell to come off scrub
all you like it'll stick around
for at least two days how does he
explain it to his colleagues and family
they'll think he doesn't know how to
wipe his ass properly
meanwhile you yourself are left with a
hand that smells like [ __ ]
small price to pay for the smiting of
one's enemies
hey fellas well well well if it isn't my
neighbor mr spinning how
damn would you feel that iron grip
handshake like bird reynolds and [ __ ]
so what's going on here oh well uh tias
and i were just discussing
a few of his lesser points of which he
does have many
hey look at that ring what is that that
is uh
my uh junior college classroom come loud
i also hope to come loud one day
preferably in a 69.
[Laughter]
say would you like a chocolate covered
pretzel
they're a little melty but damn are they
exquisite and if i remember correctly
you're a big pretzel fan
um uh dark chocolate yeah no no no
oh come on
thank you
oh
very nice and you know being a man
who uh believes in one good turn
deserves another
i have something well
both of you really what's that
hey kids did you like that all these
movies are available on itunes or
netflix in some places
amazon and other places you can find
them they're available
patronize them if you will uh also if
you like this kind of stuff
come on over to that kevin smith club go
to that kevin thatkevinsmithclub.com
join up man i do wake and bake three
times a week where i wake up just smoke
weed with you all and stuff come to that
kevin smith club for more
video antics with kevin smith